con las consignas de Orgullo y
tolerancia a la comunidad lgbtq de
Jerusalén realiza su marcha anual la
primera bajo el actual gobierno israelí
de extrema derecha y Ultra religioso los
participantes defienden masivamente sus
derechos Más allá de que en los últimos
días crecieron las amenazas en línea y
de que paradójicamente quien supervisa
la seguridad del evento es el ministro
extremista está Marvin que en el pasado
abogado por la cancelación de la marcha
un motivo más para asistir a la cita la
verdad que es una fecha muy importante
especialmente acá en Jerusalén estamos
frente a un gobierno
de ultraderecha donde esta marcha es
súper importante porque están Todo el
tiempo intentando sacarnos nuestros
derechos las cosas que el gobierno dice
sobre las personas rgbti legítima a
aquellos que nos discriminan en el lugar
de trabajo en las calles y sabemos que
en Israel en los últimos meses la
discriminación en la sociedad ha
empeorado mucho unos 2000 policías se
movilizaron para garantizar la seguridad
del desfile mientras A pocas cuadras de
aquí grupo de extrema derecha realizan
una contra marcha con lemas fóbicos y
violentos la marcha también fue
repudiada por el grupo islamista
palestino jamás amenazas y actitudes que
no amedrentan a quienes luchan por su
lugar en una ciudad marcada por el
conservadurismo religioso ciudades como
Jerusalén no son amigables con la
comunidad lgbtiq si no no se presentamos
y les mostramos que somos parte de la
ciudad y que demandamos ser vistos
estamos en riesgo de que nos quiten
nuestros derechos
la atmósfera se está volviendo más
peligrosa la gente se siente insegura y
es un impacto directo del gobierno
actual mientras su mensaje sea que no no
se reconocen o que nos desaprueban
el último reporte de la organización
aguda para la comunidad lgbtq reveló que
en 2022 se duplicaron las denuncias de
agresiones en el área de Jerusalén
respecto de 2021 una muestra más de que
todavía queda un largo camino por
recorrer hacia la igualdad y la no
violencia contra el colectivo aquí en la
ciudad Santa